we have the honor to be here once again
with andrew kramer you tackle one thing
at a time the lighting we need global
illumination now we gotta figure out how
to make eyes look real
it's the most identifiable element let's
just see if we can find it in some of
these shots here
thanks skillshare for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end to see how
you can get a free trial of a premium
membership
hey what's up andrew kramer here and
welcome back to another very exciting
episode of vfx artists react
so good wonderful man it's like i have
my headphones i sit at my computer
ready to learn let's go let's go chances
are you guys know who andrew kramer is
but
if you don't andrew basically has done
the entire world
of vfx artists and indie filmmakers a
huge favor and basically taught
everybody how to do visual effects
andrew's video pilot has been around for
a very long time you'll see a lot of it
on tv
sometimes in movies and we actually
might see a couple things and some of
the clips we have today just maybe
andrew can you tell us a little bit
about what you're doing these days we've
been doing a lot of
software development lately they call it
software development hell except
it's worse than hell actually there's
this funny meme talking about vfx he
says
vfx is easy it's like riding a bike
except the bike's on fire and the
ground's on fire and everything's on
fire because you're in hell
that's a good one oh
cw is always a gold mine
wow
it's pretty crazy looking
[Music]
dude i'd be so scared i used to have
this hulk hogan action figure looks
exactly right
gutsy is going to do a full cg character
in the tv show knowing all the
constraints
it's a really challenging thing to do a
character that's full cg
in daylight you know you often see this
with like a creature
they'll film it sort of surreptitiously
or you can
feel their presence but as soon as you
really have a full shot where
they're having to pose in a kind of a
dramatic way and you have the time
constraints of the tv show where
maybe you're working on it for a couple
of weeks and you have to try to create
this massive shot it's a big task to
pull off michael
the transition was really cool with the
pains and displacements yeah it was
really good like the way his fingers
move there is so good that to me though
like with the veins on it
that looks like a prosthetic but then
look at the shadow under the thumb it
kind of looks a little fake so i wonder
if i wonder if it really is cg
he might have that prosthetic on he's
hiding it there
he reveals the practical element there
and then they might be doing some stuff
on the fingers i think it's cg the whole
time maybe it is cg because actually the
hair on the arm you see the mat
doesn't quite cover over that hair and
so they're putting the cg arm
over the hair and they just didn't roto
out the hair i think it's a testament
how good the effects are for this
opening shot
i mean it looks great this is definitely
the money shot
it's weird because if you freeze frame
it he looks fine
but it's the animation i see what
they're going for but i feel like
there's like a
five percent weirdness in the proportion
that's not what they were going for it
is what it feels like
the animation is just one of those
things like you just have to put in the
time i'm sure the animator had all of a
day to do all these shots
and if you don't have the time you're
gonna get as close as kid maybe have a
janky motion capture
that's still going to need work to turn
it into this creature you can't just
paste a regular
human's motion capture onto it and have
it work the people who do the creatures
the best
you know they really build their system
around
bones and muscles and they really think
about the mechanics of how
the character moves you know you kind of
feel like it's more being
warped as it's moving rather than
sticking to like a formation of a
character rig
that creates kind of like a clay feeling
versus a real rigid strength that you
know you see from planet of the apes
where the characters just feel
so powerful and grounded yeah i think
this shows the benefit of how far
rendering
technology and lighting simulation has
come because at any point if you pause
it the composite matches the color
levels match all that hdri technology
that's all here and it shows and the
renderers like the renders look really
good
yeah but you still end up with a very
challenging problem that really hasn't
been solved and it goes all the way back
to the beginning of cartoons which is
the motion
some person has to sit there and just
guess how does an eight foot tall
dude punch when he's got arms that are
bigger than a tree there's so many
nuances to motion
on top of the acting and performance
that you have to do it's really
challenging so andrew you mentioned weta
and how they do a good job and
when i saw district nine that movie blew
me away
i couldn't stop staring at those
creatures obviously i know they're fake
but they look so good
compared to what we just saw why does
this look so much better what makes it
look real good to me is the contact with
the ground the walking the weight
you can see the real character's shadows
going across
the cg character's face that make them
feel like they're close to each other
because they're actually affecting each
other's light source
even stuff like simulation of cloth and
things like that just those subtle
things that make it feel connected to
the world i'm gonna go and have a little
chat with you
i mean there's a couple of other things
happening here outside just like the
rendering and the animation being good
there's way more involvement with the
camera it's handheld it's low shutter so
it's
blurry when it moves you know if your
animation is hard to do for your
character but then your camera's moving
all over the place with actual human
motion
that hides a little bit of your
animation they're definitely firing on
all cylinders here with tracking and
lighting and the way it's animated feels
real and to be fair i'm guessing
that these guys had more time than the
cw
probably for sure for sure you tackle
one thing at a time it's like okay the
lighting we need global illumination now
we gotta figure out how to make eyes
look real
the contact shadows of the ground
painting not the guy who did the mocap
oh right dude i can't oh my god
you guys can appreciate that from the
unnamed robot
series i mean i think what makes the
prawns feel like characters
it's the eyes the animation and then the
story
oh yeah you know just setting up a good
dilemma thank you boy
and go home you have to make it don't
let me go through all of this and not
make it
you understand and you know what it's
just a parallel of real life you know
you're getting invested in it and this
guy could be a rock
it doesn't matter it could be a blob the
same emotions would happen when this
movie came out for the budget of this
movie
the quality is just incredible the
amount of visual effect shots that were
in this movie to pull this off when this
movie came out
still blows my mind hey if we brought a
smile to your face or if your
brain grew just a little bit then
subscribe because we got a lot more of
these guys
and they're fun to do
i've seen this before this is really
impressive so cool there's something
that's just magical about this stuff
it's so cool like all the news
channels would all have some cool
animation that was like handmade
oh that's really cool wow just using a
moire effect
is it water or moire um let's leave that
in the comments what do you guys think
write it out in the comments what you
think it should be i think i say more i
mean it's french right who knows
so this is actually a physical sculpture
of these like chrome
lips that's awesome and then the way
that they did that like with like a
slow shutter and these lights spinning
on this thing that's real it's like a
little light rig
that's so ingenious all these tricks man
god dang i guess we
all do the same stuff we're just punched
over a keyboard slightly less charming
is it yeah definitely
doing things with computers i've done it
for long enough that it's like okay
i could see how i would do this or that
but some of this stuff like those lights
coming across
these magic tricks that like blow my
mind and i'm just like how do you how do
they even come
up with this stuff yeah man so much work
just fun to see
how they had a vision and they still
you know were ambitious enough to kind
of pull something like that off
did you guys ever see the sheet music
for the thx logo no believe it was to
demonstrate all the frequency ranges
they could do then coming down to one
uniform note i kind of miss it because
it was a great demonstration of like all
right here's the dynamic range of the
piece you're about to watch from low to
really loud is that good
turn it up turn it up it's kind of a
nice little calibration you could do at
the very beginning just the whole idea
of the sound design that went along with
more abstract visuals there's nothing
you've ever seen before i feel like this
was some kind of big promise of cg back
in the days was being able to do these
kind of really abstracted
impossible creations so the one we did
is the 2019 one
whoa so crisp it's like
so much more advanced already
jeez damn those colors are great are you
throwing back to some of the other logos
there yeah so we use like the plants
from
the other life one we have the dragonfly
you know we bring text back here
yeah there's that robot wow it's like a
mix of everything that's crazy
so there's no way that's one project
file
and then you hit render and went to
sleep yeah it's like all right guys
we're gonna fire this obviously in two
weeks
the space scene is one scene and it
turns into the background right here
behind the mountains
so then the mountains is another scene
but you did have to stitch
them together we wanted you to be able
to look at it go out of focus and be
distorted but we really tried to stretch
out the overlapping of the two cameras
but of course
we couldn't do it all in one scene it
would just be impossible although
there's some guy out there it's like i
did it
some 3d software works better for
specific things so like octane
is just does amazing stuff with like
organic and nature
and uses a physically based system so
when you're really up close and you're
seeing the translucency of the dragonfly
wings and the water drops in the same
scene
it really has just some of those great
physical properties and then a scene
like the city where it's really massive
redshift just had
some memory management tools that just
allowed us to blend the two scenes
together
and then part of it is just some artists
prefer to work in this program and some
artists prefer to work in that program
and
you know at the end of the day it's like
hey make it look good and um you know
we'll go with that you know when they
came to us to do this project
they wanted to be 4k they wanted to be
you know this intricate film
there was ways to see it in certain thx
theaters
i got a chance to see it in a theater
and you know it was like pretty
amazing sorry kids um just watch it on
the phone there
i watch it i watch it on my phone a
million times
i do have one last thing in 2009 andrew
put out a pack of visual effects
elements which have been used millions
of times the world over
things like muzzle flashes smoke and
blood hits
there's one blood hit in particular
where it goes it makes an
x it's the most identifiable element i
almost feel like it's become the wilhelm
scream
for vfx artists
i feel like it's hidden in almost every
bloodshot in
season one here of walking dead so let's
just see if we can find it in some of
these shots here
oh there's one there there's
this is actually a pretty good composite
you know why i think it actually works
good here is because i think she's
actually moving in slow motion and the
elements
are captured in slow motion which was
kind of an interesting
challenge when you're shooting vfx
elements because film is 24
frames per second but when you're doing
something exciting you want to do
something slow motion having a higher
frame rate to work with
is nice but things like liquids they
move so fast
that they kind of just look like a blur
and if you speed up something that was
shot
in slow motion it looks too choppy and
then it doesn't look
like real blood either so the solution
is actually is to shoot blood elements
at native frame rates like 24 or 30 and
do some of the slow motion stuff
unlike an explosion which is kind of an
arbitrary
phenomenon it doesn't necessarily look
bad if you speed it up or slow it down
because
with all of the glow and all the other
things you don't notice as much but
things like
liquids that are close up you can't just
speed them up
so i give that a nine out of ten
oh there it is that's it yeah it just
freezes also
boom there it is yeah this is this is
the clearest
cleanest shot the x yep can't be more
obvious than that
just that one element the guy dropped it
in wrote the guy's arm
called it a day came back the next day
and did it for 20 more shots
good for that guy when you see your
stock elements pop up in films and tv
does it distract you
if it's bad sometimes but i also
see it often used so well it's fun
listen i filmed these like in the back
of this parking lot blowing up little
packets of blood
and trying to use a green screen to keep
it all in frame
maybe we'll come out with the new
collection that has everything all
thought out
even better maybe we've already been
working on it for the past two years
i mean look maybe we don't know if you
guys have any
movies or tv shows where you see the
classic blood x
leave a comment down below we'll take a
look break it down is it good is it bad
we'll find out everybody it is a new
year happy new years and it's a perfect
time to make some new year's resolutions
so i'm here to talk about today's
sponsor
skillshare skillshare is a site
dedicated to learning to teaching you
something new and whether you're
somebody who's doing it for a career
or somebody who's just doing it for fun
skillshare has you covered everything
from creative photography and video
lessons or even just
how to grow nice houseplants skillshare
has everything
you need members get unlimited access to
thousands of inspiring classes with
hands-on projects
and feedback from a community of
millions and most classes are under 60
minutes with short lessons to fit any
schedule
there's no ads and they're always
launching new premium classes
and it's less than 10 a month when you
have an annual subscription i spent a
little bit of time on skillshare to see
what kind of cool classes they had and
one caught my eye in particular
it's a lesson on how to find your own
style because there are certain patterns
and nuances and things that you bring to
the table that are part of your voice
it's taught by andy j pizza yes the
inventor of pizza himself
no i'm kidding so if you would like to
learn something in this new year we'll
head on over to skillshare.com the first
thousand people to click the link in the
description below
will be offered a free premium
membership trial
so go check it out and now back to the
episode so we may say goodbye to our pal
andrew andrew thank you so much for
coming out here it's really great to see
you again is there anything in
particular you think people should check
out right now you're working on i think
if anything if you're interested in
visual effects
it's really approachable we have a
plug-in that's free called saber
it does some really cool light effects
back in the day when i started doing
visual effects
it was lightsabers it was my very first
effect little by little our knowledge
grew so if you guys
want to get started on visual effects
never be afraid to just jump in with one
thing
oh for sure for sure it's a really fun
thing to learn so i mean definitely
check us out at video copilot we've got
a couple of really cool new plugins
coming out and when those uh drop
uh we'll let you know